this year marked 190 year anniversary
since the start of diplomatic relations
between Russia and Greece as well as 25
years since the signing of the suit
treaty of friendship and cooperation we
have always strived to construct our
down dialogue on the basis of mutual
respect and this was the way in which
our negotiations and talks today here
took place we have discussed issues of
our regional and international
cooperation we have discussed boosting
our cooperation in the number of areas
and have signed a number of documents as
you have just witnessed we have
emphasized investment cooperation which
is developing in a very positive way
last year trade rose by 27 percent up to
almost four billion dollars in January
to September this year it it rose by 11
more percent direct mutual direct
investment our over 700 million dollars
we have a commission on scientific and
technical cooperation which is achieving
a lot of results we have had a Joint
Commission on the 1st of December which
helped us prepare for this talks the
extension of direct talks it's a further
helped by the work of the Russia Greece
Business Council which hosted two
sessions this year in March in Moscow
and in Athens in October I'd like to say
that Athens delegation has always been
actively participating in the st.
Petersburg International Economic Forum
we have that next year business circles
and government officials of Greece will
also send their delegations to st.
Petersburg of course the energy sector
is an important area of our cooperation
for many years
Russia has been providing energy
resources to Greece covering over half
of the Republic's need for gas and oil
we are ready to discussing the idea of
joining Greece to our large scale
project we have discussed cooperation in
the innovation sphere on the basis on
the declaration of partnership Russian
high-tech companies are aimed at moving
into the Greece Greek market with their
wide spectrum of products and services
of course we have discussed cooperation
in the humanitarian sphere joint
cultural festivals and exhibitions and
festivals have been very successful in
2019 we'll have a cross-cultural year of
language and culture between our three
countries we've also had a
cross-cultural year of tourism a year of
tourism between Russia and Greece last
year a Ricker record number 850 850
thousand Russian people have visited
Greece we believe that next year this
number will rise up to a billy up to a
million we have agreed to promote
tourism and we would like to see more
and more Greek nationals coming to
Russia in this regard we are
implementing projects to organize
cruises in the Black Sea and in other
areas we have signed over 20 Russian
cities have signed agreements with
Greece
from Russia's side Moscow st. Petersburg
and rostov-on-don have been leaders in
terms of the number of contracts they've
signed with Greece Greek companies
Greece is also very important in terms
of Russia's relations with the EU and we
have talked a lot about the Cyprus issue
in conclusion I'd like to think that I'm
thankful to mr. tsipras for these very
useful and detailed talks thank you
thank you so much I would like to thank
mr. Putin for this hearty welcome for
his hospitality and of course I'd like
to thank him for these very interesting
discussions we've had about all of the
issues that regard Russia Greece
cooperation as well as a number of
issues pertaining to regional and
international security as mr. Putin has
said I have come here in a year that we
we are marking the not 190 year
anniversary since the start of our
diplomatic relations our diplomatic
relations are based on a large number of
connections on ties on spiritual ties
cultural ties and many others between
our two nations I believe that this is
an important basis that allows us to
create relations spanning very long time
that are still very dynamic and positive
it's my third time here in the Kremlin
and in my third time as Prime Minister
that I am the time in Russia I have also
been to the Economic International
Economic Forum in st. Petersburg it was
a very difficult time for Greece
whiskey various the decision of our
government which was welcomed by Russia
to was to create constructive relations
between Russia and Greece after almost
five years of basically doing nothing in
the period that has passed since then we
have seen multi-layered policy complex
policy of Greece aimed at creating good
relations with Russia and Greece has
shown that it can be au EU country and a
NATO country but at the same time can
have a strong and complex political and
economic relation with Russia now three
and a half years later I am here once
again in a very new environment Greece
is finally out of this this crisis
period it finally returned to positive
economic growth and now we see this
opportunity to look into the future with
optimism this means that we have more
and more positive grounds for believing
that our relations with Russia will grow
even more productive and mutually
beneficial
of course we are facing more and more
challenges and Greece is a country
that's a pillar of stability and
security in our region which is quite
destabilized certainly Greece is
affected by the situation in the region
I'm talking about the migrant flow
of course I'm talking about the crisis
of security in the eastern part of the
Mediterranean Sea I can see that Russia
has also been very successful in terms
of its political and economic dynamics
in this very fragile but important
region so we have agreed with mr. Putin
that dialogue in this new environment is
ever more important of course this
dialogue is not easy as shown in summer
as we've seen because of what happened
in summer but our desire is to see our
future relations to remain stable and
this framework of stability have has
taken us a long time to create we want
our relations to be based on mutual
respect and so with regard to that we
have discussed what happened in the
eastern Mediterranean we have discussed
the new energy map still forming in the
region we have discussed relations of
both our countries with Turkey and I
have expressed our concern with regard
to new projects armed aimed at arming
Turkey and raising the military
capacities of Turkey we have discussed
the new energy map currently forming in
Eastern Europe we have discussed the
Nord Stream 2 we have discussed the
possibility of of taking the Turkish
stream through Greece to Italy to Europe
this project together with other
projects would raise the role of Greece
in the region and in Europe
I have emphasized for mr. Putin how much
I respect Russia for this table for its
stable position with regard to the
Cyprus issue and for I have thanks Putin
for its support of the Cyprus Republic
and I have emphasized the great role of
the Security Council of the United
Nations that helped us one day to
resolve this conflict once and for all
we have discussed prospects for peace
and security in Syria and Libya we have
discussed the need to create government
of national unity and have discussed the
idea of creating maintaining military
and security in Syria and Libya we have
discussed the Balkans a region where
stability development and security are
very important to us mr. Putin gave me a
chance to explain the position of Greece
especially on the very sensitive issue
of the country of our northern neighbors
because for Greece for the Greek people
it is a very important issue the
neighboring country should not have as
their constitutional name the name
Macedonian Republic the Republic of
Macedonia because for us for us this
name in the history behind it is a very
important part of the historical and
cultural heritage of our country and
that's why I am sure that the agreement
the that has been reached is a just
agreement
this problem needs to be solved and I
think that any nationalistic tendencies
that could destabilize this region that
problem has been solved we have also
agreed the situation the relations with
the European Union and I emphasized the
importance of the dialogue especially
when we disagree on certain issues and
especially now in the relationship the
important framework agreement on nuclear
weapons and like it was in difficult
moments difficult times during cold cold
war the dialogue was an important
instrument for settling arguments so
that we could not so that we would not
allow for the escalation of the conflict
Greek is a member of the European Union
and NATO and has to follow fulfill its
obligations but we think that any
security architecture any security
initiative in solvent international
problems would have to include Russia
and that should be should be based on
the sincere dialogue with Russia and
that is my permanent position in
permanent stance that I've been voicing
in the past three years at all
international forums where I represented
Greece as its prime minister and as part
of this we also discussed the
development in the sea of azov and in
the Black Sea of course we have some
interests there because their other 130
thousand native Greeks living in me
living in Mariupol and I would like to
thank President Putin for
the detailed report detailed information
that I was given and I would also like
to say that besides the agreement that
we signed yesterday there was the
eleventh meeting of the
Intergovernmental Commission and we
spoke about a number of issues in
different areas
Russian investments in infrastructure
and energy and we agreed that we would
promote the Greek exporters in Russia
especially in agricultural products and
food in the food industry and I told mr.
pudding that we will have an honorary
consulate in Russia and I think that it
would strengthen our relations and to
sum it up as mr. Putin said 2019 is
going to be the year of cultural
cooperation between Russia and Greece
it's a year of the language and
literature and its goal is to emphasize
important initiatives such as
translations of books into our languages
and teaching languages that our
universities and other exchange programs
and I think the many years of friendship
and mutual respect between our peoples
be people is built on a special
relationship in our appreciation for our
culture's our respective cultures I
would like to think the Russian
President and say that it was a very
constructive time constructive visit and
it happened at the right time and it
will help to continue in deepen our
important cooperation and our sub
substantive dialogue in the future with
and now let's move on to the question
two questions from each side let's start
with our guests hello in your previous
meetings in Russia Greece was under the
memorandum and everybody in in Europe
and in the in the world focused on
Greece now Greece is playing a more
important role in the region do you
would you agree with that this is the
question for both presidents yes I think
that and I already talked about that
and I stated my opinion on this and I'm
convinced that recently in the last
eight years the negative ten tendencies
in Greece have reversed it was a
difficult time but I think we've
overcome overcome it and we're
optimistic about the future we've
rebuilt most of our economy we have paid
off a lot of our debt and Greece has a
unique geographic position it could lose
its geopolitical importance but in the
last three-and-a-half years we our
foreign policy has proved that we could
be at both a member of the European
in Union and NATO and also continue and
strengthen our historic relations and
friendship with other countries and be a
stabilizing factor in the Balkans and
eastern Mediterranean and Greece is in a
good position now we've handled the
economic crisis as well and now this
friendship and historic partnership
could give us more opportunities and
during this instability in the region we
could follow our principles and our
values of cooperation and continuing
dialogue and we can play a positive role
and we could become a country that will
build bridges and friendship between
your the European Union and Russia and
also the Arab world and also at the same
time we can imply an important
stabilizing role in settling the
security issues in the region and also
the challenges that have to do with
energy security in of Europe Greece or
rather the Greek people are living for a
very difficult period in their history
and certainly we should for them to
overcome these difficulties as soon as
possible
we are following what's the Greek
government is doing and I can
congratulate mr. tsipras that has he has
been very straightforward and very
constructive in his stance to improve
and strengthen the Greek economy we have
always supported since Greece's
independence we have always supported
with this country and we will continue
to do so
regardless of what times the Greek
people are living through weather times
are difficult or not and the reason for
that lies in our deep historic roots in
our spiritual closeness and certainly
would be happy if you were fine to
overcome all of your difficulties
because that would give us new
opportunities to bolster our cooperation
you must know that one of our companies
Russian companies in is investing over
four hundred million dollars into your
country and I am sure that once the
situation with your economy stabilizes
other companies will also engage in
these activities
because we have a very strong investment
capacity and we wish the Greek people
and the Greece government to overcome
all of these difficulties they still
face as soon as possible and now Russian
journalists toss veronika Roman in cover
this is for both leaders I would like to
clarify after today's negotiations
today's talks can you say that not very
good page in the relationship between
Russia and Moscow has been turned
something that happened last summer this
past summer the diplomatic conflict in
our we are ready to do mutual projects
now with regards to the page of history
you mentioned I think there's one thing
I should say well first of all since the
very start we did not agree with the
basis for the the expelling of our
diplomats I don't think that anyone
either in Russia or in Greece believes
that
is just trying to undermine increase in
any way or weaving some conspiracies or
something this is nonsense if the
intelligence services have some
questions to to one another there are
many ways many pathways to resolve such
problems without any theatrics I hope
that this page is indeed turned but I
must say that we weren't really impeded
in any way by that problem we have good
relations in terms of our Kannamma
cooperation and other areas it's
important to have a stable economy a
stable political system and a guarantee
that there can be investments made into
our respective companies and we are
ready to continue our work in terms of
energy and infrastructure projects I
guess this was a question for me also
yes I agree with what mr. Putin said
about having to look into the future on
the rainy day in the summer doesn't mean
that there was no summer and that
there's going to be no good weather
ahead I would like to emphasize
emphasized publicly that while I'm the
prime minister of Greece while I occupy
this office and any difficult issues in
the relationship with Russia Greece does
not give in to pressure from any third
cultures and Greece was the only EU
country that in the European Council
that did not
port the desire did not support the
initiative to expel diplomats after this
crippled case but when see some cases
some incidents that concern us we have
to send certain signals certain missin
messages but we have to look into the
future and I believe that we're looking
into the future and this crisis has been
solved and now it is important to make
sure to use the opportunities for
deepening our partnership in different
sectors because in the last three years
certain steps have been taken but we
could do more certain look into more
Greek news agency my question is for the
Greek Prime Minister I would like to
hear your comments on the Cyprus
settlement and what do you think about
the strengthening relations between
Greece and the US as for the Cyprus
settlement these questions there have
been talks and if I'm not mistaken
yesterday there was a phone talk between
the two Foreign Ministries ministers and
the situation has been clarified and we
got clarifications from both sides on
the Cyprus issue it's a difficult
geopolitical situation but we always
have to make sure that we are guided by
humanitarian
ideas I don't know of any initiatives
that would be anti humanitarian this is
the position of the Cyprus republic
there are no initiatives to weaponize
the island and we do not want third
parties involved if we were supporting
this idea we would support weaponization
using force in settling this crisis but
that's not our ideas of how we should
handle this and also there is a balanced
policy at the seaports regarding all
partners including Russia and then you
asked about the Greek and US relations
and if there is a negative impact on the
relations between Russia and Greece I
think we've proved that Greek Greece
could be a trustworthy Ally both in NATO
and European Union and at the same time
be a loyal partner who keeps and deepens
historic ties and in cooperation and I
believe that there's a its own dynamic
in those relations and deep roots and
these relations
there is just no controversy there on
the contrary I believe that both our
ally NATO allies including the US and
European Union we are in the
country and Russia on the other side
have to use this value and the position
of Greece to their advantage Greece is a
trustworthy Ally and the stable sincere
partner of Russia and that's why Greece
is valuable to Russia it's not it stands
out it's not like other EU countries to
Russia so Greece could become a bridge
and we want to become that bridge and in
order to do that we want to build our
foreign policy based on including
different countries different size but
also historic values and eternal values
such as respect for international law
cooperation and promoting peace and
stability and security and that is the
foundation that we build our foreign
policy on and we will continue to do so
so I believe that we are loyal partners
and important allies for Russia as well
it's a question from the Russian media
now life you said that during the talks
you raised the issue of energy
cooperation energy security is how
realistic that one of the lines of the
Turk pipeline will go through Greece
because we see all the pressure from the
United States how are you going to
overcome that pressure and that's a
question for both leaders and also a
personal question for the prime minister
of Greece you said that the Greek
economy is being restored and it's
growing
when are you go and when you get finally
going to wear a tie
speaking about the pipelines I've just
said that we are ready together with
Greece to implement large-scale
infrastructure and energy projects and
what I meant by that as also the
[Music]
introducing basically bringing the
pipeline to Europe through Greece we
have been discussing this with our Greek
partners this is quite probable so we
can basically build a pipeline from
Greece to Italy
actually the pipeline is built but
there's still no natural gas there so
let's think about how we can add the
actual product to the mix so this
requires some further deliberations in
terms of because we need to discuss and
iron out some economic issues but we
believe that this is quite probable
quite feasible Greece supporting the the
principle where we receive energy from
different sources
we support diversification but this
principle means that we should increase
the number of possible energy sources
not excluding certain energy sources and
we think that inside the European Union
there are two there are two their double
standards right now on the one side on
the one hand there is a desire to
develop turkey island pipeline but there
are also certain obstacles and
not to build that line through Greece
and Italy but we think that there's
going to be understanding at the level
of the European Commission that double
standard is inadmissible we should not
have double standard 80% of the of the
pipeline is basically ready that brings
gas from Azerbaijan to Europe and I
think that we have all necessary
technical conditions to include Russian
gas in that pipeline as well because I
think that will benefit the European
economy and cooperation in the whole
region and that has been our approach in
the last three and a half years and we
will continue to promote it at all
European forums sorry you didn't answer
my question about the tie I guess you
didn't me missed it
I've already put on a tie but then I
just took it off quickly a tie it's just
like it's a noose on the neck of the
Greek people I think it's important
symbolism
if mr. Putin gives me this present maybe
at our next meeting I will wear his
present